hello there reject nation I'm Greg I'm
John old this odd word trailer
apparently dropped while we were out
watching Rocket Man people look out for
that review kids who like Pixar films
whoo and Elton John yeah I will do a
review that our musical biopic for just
you children anyway
onward oh wait I do know about this but
it's not around the Campea show this is
the the Chris Pratt Tom Holland movie
yeah yeah okay yeah Julia Louie Dreyfus
said the thing about monsters University
the director and I was like oh that
sounds familiar than I remember it yeah
okay cool
[Applause]
[Music]
as a punchline come
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's garbage for the trash can
[Music]
[Music]
strange Aaron it's totally a quest
all in the buff Chris Brown yeah ma'am
playing another American
it's like least American accent in
person anything is it an American
accident that spies in this guy's
trailer to do generations of children
are going to grow up not knowing that
he's actually pretty it looks kind of
like Zootopia meets bright or light
Zootopia meets Shrek a little bit
without people or something like that
like with no humans right has all like
the mythical creatures and they're all
living amongst us and today we should be
like in this specific society Jean you
go first what did you think just the
general concept of this trailer doesn't
blow my mind but just the flow of it and
the way they rendered their take on you
know magic mythical creature world
really charmed me and actually I don't
laugh a ton I don't always laugh at
trailer jokes but the jokes and this
trailer got me and just I don't know I
know the vague idea of what the plot
about this is supposed to be but
generally I just enjoy kind of getting
to know the world a little bit it felt
like an iced teas to me here's the
dynamic between our two leads here's the
sense for the voices I feel like in an
alternate universe Jack Black would have
been the crisp rack but I don't know it
doesn't yes seem like the most
mind-blowing original concept from them
but I'm just really excited to see an
original from Pixar again I think is the
main thing I took away from this really
because yeah I don't know like I feel
weird almost about prospects of Toy
Story 4 like I have so many thoughts and
weird expectations whereas this is kind
of what I enjoy the most about Pixar
still is that sense of discovery and
that sense that all when they're gonna
take me to a new world you know I don't
have any expectations so yeah I don't
know I'm curiously intrigued in a very
open kind of way by this I'm not really
worried so much as I'm just like yeah
let's go yeah I don't know I don't know
you don't but now that's my favorite the
favorite I don't know John that that
affirmation phrase come on you gotta
have more self-confidence no think of it
this way I don't know don't matter the
way I put it out there is like me
crossing a bridge and each I don't know
is a new stone and it's a prompt for me
to figure it out and thus cross this
stones you need some Sun of confidence
here yeah this looks like a DreamWorks
Animation moving to me this doesn't feel
like Pixar at all to me this looks like
a Sherlock Holmes kind of weird like I
get you while I like the idea of them
doing a complete original again I agree
with that sentiment simultaneously from
what we're getting just with this tease
it doesn't feel very just doing another
sequel to something same time it's uh I
guess I didn't feel that charm that
you're talking about and I totally get I
like it's it's an intangible thing to me
it's like I can feel their hand on this
that's not saying much out of a teaser
you know like it's a it's a flimsy way
to assess this the animation to me looks
like a lot of other styles I'm like it
looks it looks like the films that I
watch that I go eh they want to be Pixar
but they're not it looks like to me yeah
it's weird I really enjoyed watching
this but from a very objective
standpoint it doesn't have anything
super new or mind-blowing to me at all
it's it's yeah mostly for me just got by
on a certain kind of charm it does leave
a very blank slate and from what I've
read of what to expect from the plot I
mean they're striking out to see if
there's a little bit of magic left in
the world I get the sense that what
they're not showing us here is that this
could have a potential to get kind of
heavy if what I've read about the plot
is true basically they lost their data
to be age where they couldn't really
remember him so like that's a bar big
drive for their characters I hope they
can whatever for him and so I hope they
keep it really fun yes so with thinking
about things like up and stuff like that
you know the more off the beaten path
movies that's what in the back of my
mind gives me hope for this but again
it's all not what's in this trailer not
every Pixar film has been like a great
truly dive into the weight I think what
people will be most excited about is Tom
Holland and Chris Pratt voice acting
together
I don't know how excited to get about I
know normally would picks our actors or
at least when they're doing recordings
they usually don't do solo recordings
the directors are pretty intent having
actors who play like Tim Allen and Tom
Hanks or Toy Story that are usually in
the same booth together that way they
could really feed off each other work
off one another and if that's the case
and how they recorded it if I if I if I
hear that that would make me excited
about them teaming up for an animated
movie if they just did their own thing
and submitted it you know what I mean
yeah it's not as exciting to me yeah
that's cool you got these famous guys
voices in here if they're actually like
having scenes together and you could
feel that that would be something where
I would really much look forward to my
first thought was the the film's I said
at the top yeah yeah hundred percent
yeah I thought a Shrek first thing
honestly but hey you know I can tell
right now just from briefly skimming
through the Pixar page here that I am
definitely in the minority I mean this
has 36,000 likes less than a thousand
bigs a lot of dicks like but well the
comments are very positive so I'm happy
because what was the last original Coco
that wasn't too long ago but you know
Coco I don't know see that's the thing
is his Pixar has entered a phase in
their lifespan where it's not always an
assured great movie anymore so that's
the thing that worries me now about
every Pixar movie is this going to be
great or is this going to be like the
good dinosaur was one where I found a
lot of things to appreciate but
ultimately I didn't find it to be a very
super memorable movie at its core I was
mostly like yeah I've kind of seen this
story it's nicely told for sure and it
looks incredible yeah but you know and
and that's what I fear this could turn
into you know at the same time and this
teaser doesn't really give you one sense
of the other this does have some like
Monsters Inc vibes and the guy did
monsters University which was the
preferred of the monsters
at worst it'll be all right it's likely
I'll be yeah would you guys think of
this trailer leave it in the comment
boxes hey before we wrap this up I would
like to give a page from the day shout
out to a woman named Adelia Chamberlain
a Delia chambo I'm gonna leave a link in
the description box I highly suggest you
guys check
and I read this prior to watching
avengers endgame the third time she
wrote a wonderful think piece the
psychological side of avengers endgame
and I loved everything she had to say we
first we talked to messages then she
wrote this piece and it really dives
into the psychology of the characters
journeys throughout and then when I saw
it a third time I was like there's a lot
of what she kind of put the forefront of
my mind so guys go check it out and sort
of stupid patreon joke about you too and
there she goes subscribers every
technician click that notification bell
see you guys soon
you